laïcité c'est la liberté de conscience
de chacun la liberté des cultes mais
avec un certain nombre de rescrit psion
par exemple il n'est pas acceptable que
au nom d'un culte on s'en prennent aux
lois de la république
on s'en prennent aux droits des citoyens
et citoyennes la liberté de croire ou ne
pas croire la séparation très nette
entre l'état et les églises
l'enracinement des lois laïques ce n'est
pas un dogme laïque ou un dogme
anticlérical c'est la liberté de
conscience est elle possible
premièrement l'unité nationale est elle
possible en dehors de l'appartenance à
un imaginaire collectif religieux la
définition de la laïcité c'est je pense
le respect de la neutralité religieuse
et notamment à l'école dans des
administrations la neutralité pour ne
pas impressionner ou faire pression sur
les individus qui se présente là le
problème n'est pas des croyances le
problème est de la manifestation
extérieure de cette croyance dans
l'enceinte des locaux scolaires et
notamment en place s'il nous excès de
mettre le foulard on y va à l'école
et puis s'il veut pas qu'on mettre le
foulard et bains ni poignées nous a
renvoyé le voile c'est un droit le voile
fait le preneur touchez pas un autre
honneur pour ce fleuron et aux pluies de
la rue de bord
allah est grand 700 personnes cet après
midi si aujourd'hui deux ans après la
laïcité ne pouvait pas accueillir toutes
les religions toutes les les
les expressions en france alors ce qui
aurait un recul terrible et si le voile
est l'expression d'une religion nous
devons accepter les traditions telles
qu'elles sont la définition que danielle
mitterrand donne de la laïcité est faux
c'est une confusion absolue s'agit pas
d'accueillir toutes les religions au
sein au sein de l'école
bien au contraire c'est tout à fait le
compte à ce débat est là il est il est
posé mais ce sont les prémices de cette
question identitaire
cette question culturelle qui traverse
tous nos sociétés qui traverse la gauche
ça d un bouleversement extraordinaire
c'est la chute du mur de berlin c'est la
fin des des blocs nous vivons déjà en
partie de la globalisation économique et
le problème identitaire est en train de
surgir avec des conséquences
à cette époque là nous ne pouvions pas
les deviner je pense que j'étais plutôt
du côté d'un ennemi cas parce que je
vois là j'ai des jt jeu j'ai accueilli
le monde pour là on accueillait le monde
et au nom des minorités on disait mais
bon c'est leur culture
ce qui est assez incompétent de dire ça
mais c'est leur culture et leurs
traditions et donc faut respecter les
choix de dd individus de 2 voilà on est
il y avait ceux compassion en fait
quitte pas très digne parce que c'est un
peu une démarche de compassion c'était
pas une démarche on leur disait vous
êtes des citoyens et citoyennes quoi et
donc vous êtes vous devez respecter les
droits et les devoirs comme tous les
citoyens et citoyennes ou lentilles êtes
quand même on va vous on vous prend
comme vous êtes quoi un peu quand même
comme ça et puis voilà donc on avait
presque une démarche un peu oui de
compassion et non pas de d'émancipation
donc je me suis mis dans la défense de
ces jeunes filles et de leurs familles
alors que j'aurais dû me placer du côté
émancipateur c'est à dire à la fois du
côté de l'école il de l'égalité à
l'école et puis du côté des femmes
de mon point de vue en tous les cas et
peut-être pas seulement du mien l'école
doit accueillir tous les enfants
mais l'école elle a des règles comme la
république dont elle est l'expression et
je vois pas pourquoi on s'est tellement
émue
à l'idée que deux jeunes filles de
gamine qui ne voulaient pas entrer dans
l'école puisse susciter une réaction
absolument contraire à celle qu'on
aurait du temps qu'on aurait dû avoir à
savoir on vous accueille très volontiers
on en parlera mais vous enlevez votre
voeu voile et c'est là aussi où je me
suis rendu compte à quel point les
politiques étaient là dans certaines
circonstances vraiment parce qu enfin au
bout d'un moment il fallait être naïf ou
détourner son regard pour ne pas voir
que ces deux jeunes filles étaient
évidemment manipuler et d'ailleurs la
façon dont elle parle
rune font que on a ressenti très bien
que l était absolument convaincu qu'elle
pouvait le faire et donc évidemment il y
avait des gens derrière elle certains et
certaines ces intellectuels comme
elisabeth badinter la fraude
gisèle halimi anticipe et surtout
transgresse du point de vue de la gauche
l'idée qu'être laïque refusé le voile
le tchador lutter contre l'intégrisme
c'est pas être de droite ou d'extrême
droite c'est profondément républicain et
donc les hommes et les femmes de gauche
peuvent parfaitement tenir ses positions
je le comprendrais plus tard j'adore ça
n'est pas seulement religieux ces
politiques ne nous y trompons guerre et
c'est surtout et c'est là que je veux en
venir c'est tout même le symbole de la
soumission et la feria risation de la
femme gisèle halimi se trompe je crois
que ce n'est pas en prenant comme bouc
émissaire six jeunes filles qu'on fera
avancer leur émancipation qu'on fera
avancer leur intégration en france
je n'ai pas trouvé encore une seule
réaction où on parle enfin de la femme
car tout de même c'est tchador c'est
pour la femme c'est pas pour l'homme
mais elle a eu du courage
si beaucoup sont fermés
je les entends vraiment gisèle a très
bien réagi
parce que on n'avait même pas analyser
ce que signifiait lgv ou le foulard au
tout début et c'est gisèle halimi cas
bien appuyé sur ce qui nous choquer
beaucoup c'est pas seulement l'arrêt de
la neutralité le respect d'une
neutralité en ne portant pas de site de
signes ostentatoires
c'était aussi marqué la nature les
obligations de la femme musulmane et qui
était je dirais exactement le portrait
de l'inégalité des sexes à l'état pur là
où gisèle halimi prend un angle qui nous
intéresse c'est quand elle dit c'est un
instrument de soumission de la femme à
l'homme alors ce qu'elle ne sait
peut-être pas à ce moment là c'est que
la seule religion qui est tenu ce propos
noir sur blanc c'est pas l'islam qui
n'écrit ça nulle part c'est la religion
catholique chrétienne c'est saint paul
qui dit que le la femme se doit à son
nom mais le et le voile marque 7-7
soumission cette dépendance est allée
jean jé pas comment vous dire c'est que
la religion chrétienne et naturellement
il bien l'esprit de personne aujourd'hui
d'accuser la religion chrétienne de quoi
que ce soit sur le sujet la position que
la plus stricte c'est à dire celle de
gisèle halimi a été très soutenue par
les féministes et effectivement qui
était une bonne partie aussi de la
gauche la gauche
plus rose je dirais que rouge
maintenant les deux de mon point de vue
les deux points de vue ne se valent pas
il ya un point de vue que nous avons été
nombreuses et nombreuses à trouver
insupportable
je préconise que les directeurs
d'établissements et les enseignants
disent à ses enfants et à leurs parents
qu'ils ne doit pas venir à l'école
dans ces conditions si il y à blocage et
si il y à refus jeudi alors l'école doit
accepter et accueillir ces enfants mais
pas plus qu'on ne juge l'église
catholique à travers monseigneur
lefebvre
on ne doit voir derrière chaque
musulmane et une intégriste en puissance
je suis dans l'hémicycle puisque je suis
chargé des relations avec l'assemblée
nationale au au cabinet du premier
ministre au cabinet de michel rocard et
je vis comme bien comme bien d'autres
qu'on pourrait appeler le début des
tourments de la gauche avec avec ses
discussions avec ses problèmes coincé
entre les principes de laïcité
même si la deuxième gauche celle de
michel rocard
même si la culture de lionel jospin sont
assez différentes
éloigné d'une vision très laïque que
représentent ces députés qui viendront
j'ai souvenir évidemment qui viendront
dans l'hémicycle avec eux ce foulard
avec ce ce fichu si un élu du front
national le faisait aujourd'hui sacré
sens aucun doute un scandale mais à
l'époque savaient sans doute choquée
mais cela était sans doute aussi un un
choc je me rappelle très bien de ce qui
se passe dans l'hémicycle et de ses
tourments et cette volonté de trouver
une position entre les positions
républicaine et
le droit à l'éducation de ces jeunes
filles et la peur sans doute de ne pas
je mets des guillemets stigmatiser les
musulmans déjà nous sommes un an après
l'élection présidentielle ou genre est
le pen a fait un bon score 15 % et nous
sommes déjà sept huit ans après
l'émergence du front national a fait
recette
rapidement envenimée mais au départ
latitude dans lionel jospin ou d'un
michel rocard est l'attitude
bienveillante d'abord d'anciens profs
pour jose par kidioui doucement on sait
aussi repérer ce qui dans ce type de
comportement tiao crise d'adolescence
bon qui d'entre nous de la génération de
deux pas de la mienne vous pouvez
oublier que les temps jeunes gens nous
avions eu les cheveux sur les épaules
avec des chemises à fleurs ce qui de
mettet nos pères dans d'étranges un
d'horreur en se demandant pourquoi nous
faisions ça et quelle raison avez nous
il n'était pas question de couper même 1
cm de cheveux on y aurait eu une dure un
viol de notre liberté insupportable on
peut comprendre qu'on soit la gauche
soit perdu au début
après tout deux jeunes filles qui qui
rentre avec un foulard et ce qu'il faut
en affaire une affaire et beaucoup
d'entre eux des gens de gauche on
pensait que tout ça pourrait s'arranger
s'atténuer elles pourraient être
convaincus
[Musique]
et c'est donc c'était pas surprenant
qu'une partie de la gauche
10 attendons de voir on va leur
expliquer c'est la ligne de françois
mitterrand un compte et ceux qui
considèrent que ce n'est pas très
important fonds il faut laisser qu'il
faut pas embêter ces jeunes filles c'est
la ligne de michel rocard et lionel
jospin françois mitterrand était venu
nous voir une journée on était à saint
malo et après au milieu d'un repas de
poisson
le président qui avait une façon à lui
de dire son mécontentement mais ils
étaient très mécontents se le sentais
très bien ma dîme enfin elisabeth de
gamine avec un foulard sur la tête ça
menace pas la république voyons c'est
pas ça c'est pas c'est pas du tout
gênant et puis me dit yves elles sont
charmants ces petites jeunes filles avec
leur poule à donc il ya une discussion
un peu plus je dirais un petit peu plus
rude rude non mais enfin je me dis que
j'étais pas d'accord du tout est bon et
il a quand même clôt la discussion mais
je savais du coup que il était plutôt
dans la position de la tolérance et moi
n'ont pas nécessairement de
l'intolérance
mais de l'intelligence on ne peut pas
tolérer justement ceci sans mettre en
péril la république
c'est cette tradition delà de la
deuxième gauche cette volonté de
tolérance et puis il y a
incontestablement la peur que la droite
et l'extrême droite le s'emparent de ce
sujet en face à cheval de bataille dont
face à cela il faut pas la suivre faut
pas épousé les thèses faut pas utiliser
les mots les attitudes de la droite oui
bien sûr je pense que socialistes et
communistes ont peut être été aveugle en
tout cas n'ont pas voulu voir
ce qu'il y avait à voir parce que il y
avait et c'est plus légitime je dirais
qu'aujourd'hui se souvenir si vous
voulez de la colonisation de
l'oppression des maghrébins et des
musulmans de ce fait je crois qu'on a
été embarqué une partie de de la gauche
et les communistes on a été embarqué
dans voilà donc par le conte est dans
mon soutien on soutient parce qu'ils
sont du côté des minorités parce qu'ils
sont du côté de d'une religion qui n'est
pas la religion je dirais comme certains
disent identitaire de la france la
religion catholique s'était donc je m'en
veux parce que ça a été certainement un
moment où mon combat féministe a été
voilà nana n'a pas pris le dessus il n'a
pas pris le n'a pas pris le
positionnement qu'il aurait dû amener
enfin voilà il y avait une gêne voilà et
je pense que si on avait ré arrêtez tout
de suite
tout de suite on a on en serait pas là
trente ans plus tard
bien sûr c'est extraordinaire d'ailleurs
de constater à travers ces images que le
débat intellectuel anticipe les
fractures non pas seulement celles que
l'on connaîtra au sein de la gauche mais
de la société française parlem très
rapidement pour la faire c'est ca est
apparu a créé vous avez pris position
vous avez dit finalement le jeans nom
portera sur le tchador
je suis contre moi à titre personnel il
faut laisser cette jeune fille parce que
c'est le meilleur moyen de pas les
exclure
mais est ce que vous regrettez pas un
peu ce que vous avez dit pas du tout les
gens qui veulent nous faire croire qu'il
se bat pour l'égalité de la femme alors
qu'ils obligent leurs femmes à porter
des voiles et qu'il ne les laisse pas
circuler librement et qui aujourd'hui
font de la provocation avec des enfants
et qui manipule ses enfants alors
j'estime effectivement que nous ne
devons pas les laisser sous prétexte de
provocation faire main basse sur ses
enfants et qu'il faut au contraire que
ces enfants là malgré le fait que dans
leur environnement familial à leur
environnement intégristes on avenue les
affubler d'un foulard ils puissent quand
même allez allez
la même école que les autres enfants
parce que là ils seront au contact d'un
autre univers
parce que par l'acquisition des
connaissances et bien ils pourront
effectivement eux aussi avoir leur
chance et réussir l'intégration ça a été
un pari optimiste que je peux comprendre
que je peux entendre tout à fait mais
c'est bel est complètement c'est un
échec parce que si on a réussi peut-être
pour certains de ces enfants de deux de
dépasser le cadre familial
vous savez si le professeur dit quelque
chose de totalement différent des
enfants ou site des philosophes pour les
ceux qui sont plus âgés qui ont des
positions qui sont directement
contraires à celles des parents les
enfants restent accrochés à la pensée
familière non ça marche pas parce que la
pression est trop forte
mais j'ai envie de dire moi j'ai
participé avec des débats à d'autres
époques avec des classes dans les lycées
après il faut une heure de bataille
j'avais du mal à admettre que ce qui
était la laïcité ce qu'étaient les
droits des individus et c'est donc le
voile ou pas voilà on s'aperçoit
quelques pas que c'est pas le voile en
lui-même qui résout le problème ça c'est
clair
c'est ce qu'il ya dans les têtes en fait
les professeurs ont été de plus en plus
désarmé devant ça au point justement de
fermer les yeux souvent et même très
souvent dans certains dieux pas partout
donc le pari optimiste était deux je
veux dire très rationnels ils avaient
mais ça s'est pas passé comme ça parce
que entre temps
l'islamisme politique avant c'est
avancer avancer devenait de plus en plus
puissants et les enfants se seraient
sentis traîtres à leur famille à leurs
quartiers à leur imam s'il avait écouté
les professeurs voilà en voulant
légiférer dans la précipitation
on fait du voile un symbole qui
marquerait qui se marquerait par des
crispations dans la société donc je
crois que c'est plutôt par le dialogue
que l'on fera reculer l'intégrisme des
proviseurs des professeurs et les jeunes
femmes vous savez qu'ils ont fait ce
mouvement ni ni soumises
tout ce toutes celles qui ont été
confrontés à ça disent s'il vous plaît
faites une loi pour que les choses
soient claires le projet de loi n'est
pas rédigé contre une population ou
contre une religion la république
garantit à tous la liberté de pratiquer
la religion de son choix
la neutralité n'est pas la négation où
il fallait une belle loi sur la laïcité
vous pouvez se donnait d'ailleurs justin
2005 n'aurait pas mis bien fêter le
centenaire la loi de 1905 la laïcité
mais une moi qui prenne en compte
l'ensemble des problèmes non analysé ma
fille emeline la loi n'est pas fait que
pour interdire la loi les flottilles
pour construire pense que les
socialistes aient aussi l'ump chacun
fait preuve d'esprit civique pour
sauvegarder l'école de la république
quelques temps après je justifie où
j'essaie d'expliquer mon propre
changement qui le changement mais
profond et je crois sincère de tous ceux
qui lisent les conclusions de la
commission stasi ou qui assistent elle
fera aussi un très bon travail à la
mission à la commission mise en place
par le président de l'assemblée
nationale jean-louis debré y est donc et
qui fait converger les opinions de
presque tous les parlementaires sur
cette loi de 2004
incontestablement il ya une évolution et
parce que les témoignages ce que nous
ressentons les uns les autres soldats un
mois député de la banlieue parisienne
nous amène je crois pour des raisons
très sincère et pas tacticienne pour une
fois a adopté cette position et
l'unanimité le fait de rechercher une
position unanime nous sentons bien que
cela donne une force incroyable à ce que
le parlement va voter oui le vote et
peut être vu comme un sursaut positifs
de la part de ce qui était pour
l'interdiction et ont effectivement
pendant un moment ça a rétabli la paix
dans les écoles
et je voyais souvent dans dans la
banlieue les jeunes filles avec un voile
mais au moment d'entrer dans le lit
c'est vraiment la porte d'ouverture et
l'anglais sans problème et elle ne remet
tait quand elle sortait et ça faisait
mon admiration
je ne pouvais pas ne pas me rendre
compte que la question de des signes
extérieurs de la pratique religieuse
avait changé de nature que c'était plus
une question qui était simplement lié à
la fois personnelles mais que ça
commençait à prendre la tournure d'une
affirmation politico-religieuse
peut-être avons-nous huit ans mais c'est
comme ça qu'on l'a vécu dans le moment
c'est sur cette base là que pour ma part
je suis conduit à prendre ma décision et
puis il s'agit de l'école
donc on se dit bon la bataille aura lieu
autour parce que évidemment que si
certaines mettent des foulards à l'école
et le mettront aussi à l'extérieur donc
confinant l'école empêchant que la
bataille entre dans l'école parce que
parce que c'est pas le lieu
c'est l'idée qu'on s'en fait à ce moment
là on se dit la bataille va avoir lieu
pas à l'école alors bon des amis nous
disent vous allez trop loin vous vous
rendez pas compte
c'est une affaire de piété vous
confondez les signe de piété avec
les batailles politiques oui bon oui on
l'entend mais c'est pareil pour tout le
monde donc la loi doit bien précisé que
ça s'applique aussi aux autres signes
religieux et du moment que la loi le
prévoit ce qui est le cas nous avons eu
en quelque sorte la conscience
tranquille parce que la loi interdit de
porter une kippa à l'école interdit de
porter des des croix monumentale
bref tout ce qui est en quelque sorte
l'affichage d'une appartenance
religieuse de nature à déclencher une
discussion de type religieuse qui tourne
très vite mal puisque par définition la
religion ne se discute pas beaucoup de
gens n'ont pas l'air de se rendre compte
que chaque religion est une hérésie pour
l'autre les religions ne sont pas
mutuellement bienveillante l'une pour
l'autre
l'oecuménisme c'est un voeu pieux de
l'église catholique qu'elle ne pratique
pas d'ailleurs elle-même tout le temps
donc nous nous savons nous qui sommes
les tenants de l'histoire longue de la
patrie que si on commence à sortir de du
rail qui conduit notre histoire depuis
des siècles ça va mal se finir ne l'ont
pas voté cette loi
je me rappelle que jean pierre brard qui
était député à l'époque de
seine-saint-denis va prendre la parole
en faisant appel aurait de le monde à
prendre la parole juste après moi
il appartenait au même groupe que moi
pour dire je ne suis pas d'accord avec
la position que viennent défendre
marie george buffet et pour annoncer
qu'il voterait pour cette loi c'est le
seul député du groupe qui a exprimé une
opinion à l'épaule différente si je
devais aujourd'hui revoter c'est toi je
la voterai parce que c'est facile de
dire ça bien sûr parce que elle a fait
ses preuves
parce qu'il n'ya pas une fuite massive
des jeunes filles de l'école publique
parce que quand vous allez à la porte
des lycées chez moi ça se passe bien ça
se passe souvent le sourire ça se passe
souvent dans les plaisanteries cetera
voilà je parle du voile donc je pense
qu'à l'époque je vais parler de moi je
vais pas mettre les autres camarades du
groupe en difficulté mais je pense que
j'ai fait une erreur pour le fait de
vouloir toujours ajouter un adjectif
laïcité ça témoigne qu'on n'est pas sûr
que ce qu'on pense de la loi sur la
laïcité
ça témoigne toujours pour essayer de
aller de tricher un peu par rapport à la
loi
alors il ya un site est ouverte laïcité
bienfaisante et israël etc
voilà s'était calmée et les monts
dirais-je les fanatiques ou les radicaux
islamiques ont attaqué alors par
d'autres biais après les écoles
s'étaient d'autres lieux c'était plus la
question du voile c'est la question de
la grande tenue islamique
enfin bon et j'ai remarqué mais je suis
pas du tout la seule que depuis que je
dirais on s'est habitué à des offensives
je dirais d'ordre religieux radical
il me semble que dans les mêmes lycées
où vous pouvez observer ce geste
nécessaire mais en même temps émouvant
de ces jeunes filles qui enlevaient
leurs voiles avant d'entrer
maintenant beaucoup pour pas dire la
plupart rentrent voilée et c'est dire à
quel point les pressions sur les jeunes
filles et sur les femmes sont fortes
parce que si on résiste à ça on est
considéré comme une traître et c'est
très douloureux pour très difficile à
assumer pour des pour des jeunes
plusieurs organisations musulmanes
voulait empêcher la parution de ce
mero spéciale de charlie hebdo à la une
du journal satirique
ce dessin de cabu qui présente une
nouvelle caricatures du prophète mahomet
l'hebdomadaire publie également les
croquis danois qui ont embrasé une
partie du monde musulman
le dessin il a aucune aucune méchanceté
nous nous sentons insultés je vois pas
pourquoi nous on défend le pauvre contre
les intégristes ou alors ils sont où il
faut faire son travail il faut continuer
comme si de rien n'était on est dans un
état de droit dans un état de droit où
l'église est séparée de l'état ça s'est
pas fait en un jour
il ne faut pas céder sur nos droits
fondamentaux on a le droit de critiquer
la religion va mettre sa vie en jeu
le citoyen ne doit pas avoir peur d'une
religion lorsqu'elle veut se substituer
au pouvoir d'état et à la loi
démocratiquement votées par les
parlements une relaxe arrosée ce soir
dans les locaux de charlie hebdo
initialement tiré à 5000 exemplaires le
numéro spécial incriminé a été diffusée
en février 2006 à plus de 400000
exemplaires
on a toujours eu de très bons rapports
avec charlie hebdo qui sont nous nous
invité permanent à la fête de l'humanité
et donc oui on était deux à côté d'eux à
ce moment là les hommes politiques
soutenaient charlie en tous les cas sur
la liberté d'expression
je n'ai pas un souvenir qu'il ya eu des
hommes politiques venus soutenir les
parties civiles
j'ai pensé j'ai pensé que c'était bien
c'était bien même si je faisais beaucoup
de bill pour charlie pour tous les cas
pour les journalistes les personnes qui
travaillaient je pensais que les hommes
politiques dans leur ensemble avaient
fait avait compris ce qui se passait
probablement beaucoup avaient compris
mais c'était bien difficile de
de prendre les décisions qui
s'imposaient les responsables politiques
sont courageux parce que nicolas sarkozy
et françois hollande soutiennent charlie
hebdo dans le procès que face aux
attaques d'un certain nombre
d'associations musulmanes qui envoie
charlie devant les tribunaux je me suis
dit c'est ces dessinateurs ce journal
leur engagement ça va leur coûter cher
je les dis d'ailleurs ça va leur coûter
très cher et ça m'inquiète énormément je
peux pas savoir en 2006 ce qui allait se
passer en 2015 mais se ressentait
saint-gerons sentais que c'était un acte
de courage qui pouvait se faire payer
cher dans la nuit tôt ce matin un ou
plusieurs individus ont cassé une vitre
de charlie hebdo balancer un cocktail
molotov à l'intérieur et ce qui a eu
pour résultat d' enflammer une partie
des locaux les conséquences c'est que le
matériel est inutilisable et qu'on peut
pas faire un journal dans dans ces
conditions là charlie hebdo charia hebdo
le rapprochement était marrant à faire
mais c'est juste c'est juste une énorme
blague
[Musique]
charbon tu as été assassinés comme tu le
pressentait par nos plus anciens de plus
qu elle nous plus constant nos plus
bornés ennemis les fanatiques religieux
traitant sanglant qui vocifèrent de
en aval intelligence vive la mort charb
ils n'auront jamais le dernier mot donc
il s'en trouvera pour continuer notre
inépuisable rébellion
beaucoup trop de gens oui que sont la
laïcité on serait pas là à discuter
tranquillement et j'ai moins peur des
extrémistes religieux que des laïcs qui
se taisent il ay qui se taisent dit elle
après l'attentât à la demande d'un
proviseur je suis allé faire un débat
dans un lycée on est resté deux heures
avec le proviseur avec une quinzaine
peut-être d'élèves de terminale les
filles étaient les plus virulentes et on
a mis deux heures à faire en sorte que l
accepte qu en france le droit à
l'agriculture la liberté d'expression
était un droit fondamental pouvait pas
remettre en cause j'espère qu'on a fini
par les convaincre
je n'en suis pas complètement certaines
parce que pourrait il y avait touché à
quelque chose horrible on n'avait pas le
droit de toucher et de débat s'est passé
avec passion mais on s'est pas séparé on
a essayé d'avancer ensemble
bonjour je pense qu'on a avancé jusqu'à
jusqu'à la dir
en france ce droit existe et on y tient
comme à la prunelle de nos yeux voilà je
pense qu'on a on a gagné ça on sent le
décrochage d'une partie de de la
jeunesse c'est ainsi par rapport à la à
la république il faut tenir parce qu'on
est face à un débat majeur
il pointe
je crois que c'est juste au moment des
obsèques de charme
bon point le silence ou le malaise d'une
partie de l'autre de l'autre gauche et
je pense que ce débat est fondamental il
bien plus important l'eba économique et
social parce que ce débat identitaire
agit comme comme un couteau dans la
plaie des débats au sein de la gauche et
est du coup c'est la société française
il faut en effet peut-être que ce qu'on
a vécu quelques jours après cet attentat
cette descente massive des citoyens et
des citoyennes dans les rues sans
distinction sans rien là vraiment
c'était une démarche quasiment
individuelle sans banderoles sans rien
est-il ce perdure c'est cette liberté
qu'il faut défendre
absolument même quand elles nous
contrarie et je pense que les croyants
pourrait avoir une fois plus forte en
dieu s'il pensait qu'il est capable de
régler ses comptes tout seul et qu'il
n'a pas besoin du bras armé des crétins
sanglant qui viennent assassiné ici ou
là pour faire régner une loi dont ils ne
sont pas chargés
il ne faut pas avoir peur de se faire
traiter d'islamophobe qui a été si vous
voulez pendant pas mal d'années
comment dirais-je le stop absolue
l'interdiction de parler hélas est
presque la suspicion sur la laïcité
à partir du moment où les gens auront
compris que c'est une arme contre la
laïcité
peut-être ils pourront laisser leurs
peurs de côté pour dire les choses
ceci dit marine le pen s'en est emparé
ce qui gêne beaucoup les tenants de la
laïcité c'est une querelle qui me paraît
inutile
on a le droit à pratiquer sa religion on
a le droit de critiquer les religions
toutes les religions y compris l'islam
mais pas l'islam plus que les autres ou
alors on s'appelle marine le pen est ce
que vous employez de mots islamophobe
non parce que je veux éviter de tomber
dans ce débat bien français de se battre
pour des musées très vite moi compris
que ce concept d'islamophobie était une
arme redoutable parce que je pense tout
à tort mais que la majorité des français
ne sont pas islamophobe c'est à dire la
haine de la religion musulmane et que
bon c'était c'était si vous voulez une
façon d'empêcher ceux qui se rendaient
compte que c'était pas l'islam qui était
critiqué mais l'islamisme qui était
critiqué
c'était une façon leur clouer le bec et
pourquoi parce que les gens comment vous
dire ça veut dire vous êtes islamophobe
vous êtes vous êtes un quoi vous
êtes à personne personne n'a envie
d'être traité de raciste de dégueulasse
surtout s'il ne l'est pas
c'était donc et ça a été un outil un
outil prix repris enfin créé par les
islamistes justement pour qu'on ne
puisse pas critiquer les idées
religieuses de l'islamisme on ne pouvait
pas c'est clair que c'est pas facile
mais c'est une bataille d'idées on ne
gagne pas des batailles d'idées de cette
nature avec des moeurs de spadassins
avec des chaussures à gros coups loup où
l'on vient avec son gros gourdin
infliger la vérité révélée à l'un ou à
l'autre
c'est absurde ceux qui s'insurgent
contre eux
ce qui est désigné par le mot
islamophobie ont des raisons sincère et
honnête
pardon mais que quelqu'un deviennent
assez délirant pour aller dire à la
sortie d'une mosquée sur des gens qui
viennent y faire des prières c'est plus
du domaine du rationnel
d'ailleurs on a dit ah ben il est fou
pas très bien ça illustre exactement ce
que veut dire le mot islamophobie une
phobie ça n'a jamais été un acte
rationnel
la phobie des araignées c'est pas
rationnel alors la phobie d'une religion
n'est pas rationnel on peut avoir l'idée
de combattre une religion son contenu et
cetera et cetera mais ce type de
comportement il faut bien admettre
qu'ils existent vous avez des gens
maintenant qu'ils réfléchissent plus
donc ça encore changer la situation
c'est pas celle de 89 c'est pas celle de
2004 on est à un point de crispation
dans la société parce que le thème a été
utilisé aussi pour faire bouillir le
pire des chaudrons nous ne saurions pas
français si nous n'avions pas des débats
sur les mots et cie ne considérions pas
les mots comme quelque chose d'important
donc c'est un peuple que nous vivons
comme ça un peuple intellectuel très
très politique très politisée j'imagine
que l'immense majorité de nos
concitoyens entre pas forcément dans ces
débats utilise les mots qu'il souhaite
mais il était évident et des abbesses
balle à terre le dit très bien que le
mot islamophobie qui vient de très loin
est utilisée pour mettre en cause la
laïcité pour faire rentrer dans le débat
public
un mot qui a ses propres ambiguïtés il
s'agit de lutter contre la haine des
musulmans parce qu'ils sont musulmans il
n'y a pas de problème il faut le faire
avec la plus grande détermination la
plus grande vigueur
mais il faut éviter d'utiliser des mots
dont on sait bien nous qu'ils sont
qu'ils sont piégés on condamne très
timidement les actes anti musulmans
parce qu'il faut surtout pas prononcer
le mot islamophobie et dans le même
temps on vient alimenter le discours
islamophobe
le discours qui vise les musulmans en
les stigmatisant sur la question de la
laïcité
le choc aujourd'hui d'amender les des
femmes entièrement voilées ça choque en
france qui me choque aujourd'hui c'est
que au nom de la laïcité on va venir
piétiner des arguments et des lois du
droit français je rappelle l'article 9
de la convention européenne des droits
de l'homme qui reprend l'article 18 de
la convention universelle des droits de
l'homme qui rappellent que chaque
individu a la droit à la liberté de
pensée de conscience et de religion et
que cette liberté peut aussi se
manifester individuellement ou
collectivement dans le public comme dans
le privé il est temps que nous prenons
acte de cette situation
je n'ai pas signé cet appel à manifester
parce que je les lui attentivement faut
mieux quand on signe un appel et il
parlait de lois liberticides
en parlant des lois françaises
donc je ne considère pas que les lois
sur la laïcité soit des lois
liberticides et donc je n'ai pas signé
je n'ai pas participé à cette
manifestation les droits des individus
existe la convention universelle
européenne
la constitution française préserve les
droits des individus et nous préservons
le droit la liberté de culte
il ya aucun doute là dessus sauf que
c'est la loi de 1905 la liberté de culte
ne veut pas dire imposer au reste de la
société cette religion cette pensée
philosophique ou contredire des lois ou
des droits en france au nom de cette
pensée philosophique ou de cette
religion et c'est valable pour toutes
les religions
voilà c'est que c'est clair et net c'est
clair et net
donc d'abord on décide de confiner
l'école pas de bataille religieuse à
l'école dont ib dans la rue chacun sabic
au mieux à que je continue à dire mais à
ras la burqa c'est un autre problème
c'est que c'est instaurer un certain
usage de l'espace public
indépendamment de la fois de la personne
qui la porte parce que nous n'avons pas
nous intervenir en la question de la foi
j'entends des arguments des fois de gens
qui disent mais met ses pas dans l'islam
c'est pas notre sujet d'apprécier ce qui
est dans l'islam qui ne s'y trouve pas
pas de religion en politique mais pas de
politique en religion les gens croient
comme ils veulent comme ils l'entendent
comme leurs prêtres le leurs conseils
mais là ça veut dire qu on présuppose
dans l'espace public des femmes me jette
à la figure le fait que mon regard est
forcément un regard concupiscent mais
enfin au nom de quoi est ce que est ce
que moi je
j'irai proclamant
quelles sont toutes des aguicheuse c'est
absolument incroyable comme point de vue
vous connaissez beaucoup de féministes
réel voilée vous connaissez beaucoup
parce que le voile c'est quand même le
symbole d'une soumission faut pas faux
pas il n'y a pas de raison de donner aux
voix la signification qu'il n'a pas
cessé et il faut protéger
n'est ce pas c'est sa pudeur parce qu'au
fond ce serait les femmes qui seraient
responsables des dérives sexuelles des
hommes et on peut parler de féminisme
dans ce cas là mais c'est une blague et
une blague que beaucoup d'ailleurs
entériné un rabbin ben oui c'est ça la
liberté
ben non c'est pas vrai je suis
aujourd'hui très inquiète de la
pénétration des idées portées par ce
qu'on a appelé un moment les indigènes
de la république dans des mouvements
jeunesse y compris à l'intérieur de
mouvements féministes
c'est à dire qu'on différencie les
droits selon qu'on est le thé l'origine
de telles couleurs de tl7 on en vient
rappelez-vous à excuser entre guillemets
je mets des guillemets des viols parce
que ceux qui ont commis les viols
étaient des migrants
on en vient à excuser des violences
faites à des femmes parce que l'auteur
des violences était dans une situation
difficile cetera ou parce qu'ils étaient
victimes de discrimination et terrestres
c'est à dire on est en train de faire
une sorte de hiérarchie des individus au
détriment de l'égalité face au droit et
ça ça me fait très peur et sacré gelé
constatées y compris des divisions au
sein de mêmes mouvements de gens qui
avant partageaient les mêmes choses les
mêmes valeurs les mêmes revendications
les mêmes exigences qui ce qui se
dispute entre eux sur ces questions on
l'a vu au sein de deux syndicats
étudiants on l'a vu au sein de
mouvements politiques de jeunesse
et je vous le dit on le voit aussi au
sein du mouvement féministe
donc il faut retrouver cette cette
égalité citoyenne qui permet justement
l'émancipation pour tous et toutes
ils qui sortent cette ire archi qui fait
qu'en fin de compte on a quand même une
attitude quelque peu élitiste et
colonial parce que quand même on va
s'occuper de ceux qui sont là qui sont
là et puis nous
donc revenons à l'égalité des droits si
je veux un peu d'espoir
c'est un conte si tous ces débats là
sont résolus et si les uns les autres
convergent des positions fortes
puissantes unis sur la défense de la
république sur la sueur sur la laïcité
peut-être à ce moment là tous les
rassemblements aux sons sont possibles
mais je pense que c'est un débat de fond
c'est un débat très profond qui acquit à
qui a bouleversé les fondements de la
gauche parce que la gauche telle qu'on
l'imaginait dans le monde des deux blocs
où les états nations
un rôle essentiel dans la conduite des
politiques se économique et où le débat
droite gauche était simple et claire
simpliste et caricatural parfois nous
voyons bien qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est plus
du tout le cas et que c'est ces
fractures sur les questions nous avons
évoqué question notamment de de l'islam
et de l'islam politique de l'islamisme
jia 10 sont demandés concept différent
cette gauche ne peut pas ne peut pas ce
ne peut pas se retrouver le fil c'est la
liberté de conscience et rendre cette
liberté de conscience compatible avec la
vie en société
car on ne peut pas raisonner de la vie
en société comme de la somme des
intérêts particuliers
il ya un intérêt général ça toujours été
difficile ne croyez pas que ça va
devenir sable parce que vous avez
proféré sur le ton du commandement une
règle vous vous trompez et si vous
oubliez un seul jour que au point de
départ de tout ça il ya l'affect humain
c'est-à-dire cette idée que nous sommes
semblables par nos besoins et donc égaux
en droits si vous perdez l'idée que
c'est une dimension affective
alors vous êtes à côté de vos pompes
vous êtes comme tous les allumeurs de
bûcher et moi je déteste ce alors oui
j'essaye de convaincre de faire marcher
ensemble de trouver ensemble de gravité
et surtout de disputer le leadership
politique parce que pour ce qui concerne
les croyants musulmans
si nous laissons croire seulement cinq
minutes que on ne peut être progressiste
on ne peut être humaniste qu'à la
condition d'être athée alors on est
complètement à côté de ce que nous
sommes dans l'histoire parce que nous ne
sommes pas le parti apte et nous sommes
le parti humaniste appareils nous sommes
le parti de la liberté de conscience
bien sûr que les gens qui sont hâtés
forme quand même le gros de la troupe
est d'ailleurs je vais vous dire
l'athéisme en france est une conviction
molle comme toutes les autres c'est à
dire que les jambons ils sont hâtés
toute leur vie perd la fin de leur vie
commence à se rendre compte qu'il ya un
problème et ils le sont beaucoup moins
j'ai connu ça dans ma famille un j'en ai
connu des drôlement virulente
ni en serrant dans leurs mains des chats
pelés et mon coeur est rempli d'émotions
en pensant à eux et je ne méprise pas
pour ça parce que je pense qu'ils
avaient peur de la mort comme tous les
hommes comme tous les êtres humains et
que ce sentiment d'être simplement
transit peut aider à affronter une
épreuve dont personne ne sait rien alors
de grâce un peu d'humanité dans nos
rapports sur tous ces rapports là
rappelez vous bien d'une chose la
violence n'a jamais réglé aucun problème
concernant les religions on a tout fait
on sait entre massacrés on sait entre
brûlé on sait on s'est obligé de force à
faire faire telle ou telle chose et ça a
toujours été contre l'esprit alors moi
je je continuerai à être ça et je crois
que c'est ça la grandeur d'un humaniste
m'ont dit laïc mais c'est l'humanisme
qui compte quand quelqu'un on peut
inventer une idée aussi étrange que de
penser que l'univers est infini et que
les mondes ils sont innombrables comme
le penser le jardin aux brunes au xvième
siècle tous les curetons lui sont tombés
dessus
ils ont fini par le brûler parce que ça
contredisait le texte et bien moi j'ai
une autre idée
monsieur qui m'a interrogé sur la façon
de rassembler les gens
la vie s'en charge regardez quand
armstrong sur la lune
qu'est-ce qui fait il y un texte la
genèse qui si on l'avait cru n'aura
jamais permis d'aller sur la lune
alors je veux bien qu à ce moment là ils
lisent la genèse ça ne me dérange pas
puisque on est arrivé sur la lune
je pensais je pense toujours que si nous
faisons la démonstration que l'islam en
france en europe raison qu'on ne
réussisse pas et est totalement
compatible avec nos lois avec l'égalité
femmes-hommes avec la démocratie avec
surtout la liberté de culte
liberté couarde pas quoi avec liberté de
la conversion etc vous ferai une
démonstration incroyable universel au
niveau du monde je pense que le débat il
est toujours il y toujours posé l'est
toujours
il est toujours là et qui au nom d'une
certaine égalité nous devions ça aux
musulmans de france mais là est bien le
débat sur les mots sur les doigts c'est
qu'à chaque fois qu'on touche aux
éléments on soulève d'autres d'autres
problèmes mais j'assume le fait parfois
en trompant d'avoir d'avoir cherché des
solutions
ce qu'il faut faire pour s'en sortir est
extraordinairement difficile à faire
parce que plus les jours passent et plus
c'est difficile
et le fait d'avoir attendu trente ans
pour mettre les choses bien au point et
ne pas prendre la responsabilité une
fois de dire non ça on l'acceptera pas
je parle du début inde et au début pas
de la loi 2004
je pense que c'est de plus en plus
difficile et j'ose à peine vous dire
parce que ça me fait une crève le coeur
qu'il me semble que dans certains
quartiers
c'est trop tard je ne vois pas comment
ça peut se passer bien et sans violence
voilà